you know what it is no let's have the
confrontation we're rolling let's have
the conversation Esther and I there's
something to say to Esther there's been
issues okay there's been behind the
scenes issues this is a sustainable
issue it's not me no no I blame little
Pastor Esther
my name is Miss Esther why don't you
stand up and show them what you've done
to young women and older women that I am
a victim no no no no no no oh what
you're gonna blame your parents for this
one yes I am I am a victim of not being
able to leave high school and when
something that I wore in high school
comes back in style I have I'm leaving
the show I'm done that's my last episode
I have to yesterday low rise do you see
the brand are they van Dutch you stupid
[__]
make your ass look good that's the the
pants fault not mine I mean
I was watching Jennifer's Body and I was
thinking like we did we sacrificed the
ass for the low rise yeah I'm not look
I'm wearing this outfit today and I'm on
a workout plan I'm doing good but Annie
you're hot no no I'm listen
I got no problems there I'm very into
myself
there's a there's a pooch situation if I
were to wear a low-rise it would be a
bubbling over everyone has been through
this we all know that but there are ways
look no but can I just say hang over it
it's disrespectful and I want you to
look into the camera and apologize I
apologize that I can't leave my
childhood behind and then I'm also
wearing Y2K era Tiffany's jewelry from
high school and last night is that
actually from high school yes oh that's
cute thank you and last night I was
trying on my old Juicy Couture zip like
I'm you know I'm mental illness okay
I'm embarrassed sponsorship with Juicy
they were asking me over the pandemic
but I couldn't they're like what are
your sizes like it's the who has people
their sizes over a pandemic I don't know
my sizes are you lost track the hell are
you talking about I I'm gonna be like I
had sex with my high school boyfriend
while wearing this I resist your some of
your looks because I don't want to be a
poser off of you but I will be we always
why
I thought that was our thing no it's
your thing you did me I don't do it back
no I will be wearing those
those burn victim arm things Esther
there's a juicy collab right now with
Aries
that's really cute I got some very cute
stuff coming in the mail I was talking I
don't think do we talk about it on air
where I've been waking up in the middle
of night and shopping no not on air
which I thought about this yesterday
when I went home after talking to you
because
there's something to me that is so
romantic and like the coolest thing ever
to wake up in the middle of the night
and do something guys okay we're done
we obviously talk about mental health
here a lot we're gonna talk about some
[__] Solutions okay since your
doctor's gonna [__] okay when you
wake up in the middle of the night and
you're spinning
you open open an app okay open a revolve
open a free people open listen you need
a budget an anxiety budget okay you put
it to the side it's actually a really
good buy yourself and honestly if you
can't afford much buy a pair of [__]
socks [__] I don't care like you buy
one article a thong or add to cart Phil
card sometimes I'll fill a card up and
do nothing with it no
you must have something there's has to
be a there has to be a a final product
arriving to your house I want to talk
about what strange things we've done in
the middle of the night
because I have a list what is it
Rusty crusty itchy [__]
you guys is it still crusty it's not
crusty it's just hemorrhaging isn't that
funny how mean it is to tell someone's
[__] crust I don't think that's mean
I came in late no listen I want to talk
about this because I'm also bleeding out
before you do can I wear one of your
tracks yes but can we explain why my
track is like so busted the dice can we
the Dyson
air stuff just dries
I returned it what it's trash for me I
think it works for other people for my
hair and for hair that doesn't have real
moisture in it it just sucks out the
moisture okay that's freshly washed what
are your I was just gonna say you said
that men should be the only ones left to
wash their hands yeah we're bloody
diarrhea monsters get a baby wipe
there's no I can absolutely change a
tampon and not need to wash my hands
after that's true I need you to watch
this it's not about you and your comfort
it's about our comfort level around you
you stinky nasty tuna [__]
you've never smelled my vagina come
smell it and tell me I haven't had to
try Esther yes I have smell driven no
you haven't I'm right here I can smell
it come here put your nose in there and
you tell me what I'll turn this into
that fantasy for you
you're asking for it
thank you to our sponsorship station in
a landscape where free and fast shipping
is the norm it can be hard for smaller
e-commerce businesses to compete keep
yourself competitive with ship station
use code trash Tuesday today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's shipstation.com
promo code trash Tuesday for your 60-day
free trial our next partner is athletic
greens I take ag1 by athletic greens
literally every day I gave ag1 a try
because I wanted to nourish my body with
all of the vitamins and minerals up
front in the beginning of the day so
that I wouldn't have to think about it
for the rest of the day if you're
looking for an easier way to take
supplements athletic greens is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to athleticgreens.com
Tuesday that's athleticgreens.com
Tuesday check it out hi sluggies I'm so
excited to be on the road with the
welcome to anniewood tour I can't wait
to see you guys meeting you guys is so
fun I cannot wait to see all of you each
and every one of you everywhere I go you
can see me this weekend in Washington DC
I'll then be in Seattle Washington March
10th and 11th I'll be in Tampa Florida
March 17th and 18th those two are going
to sell out immediately I'm gonna be in
Toronto Canada April 21st and 22nd I'll
be in Raleigh North Carolina May 12th
13th I'll be in Salt Lake City in June
I'm going to be in Calgary at The Great
Outdoors Comedy Festival with Andrew
Schultz in August I have a lot more
dates that are being added so please
make sure you check any lettermen.com
shows and as always on Thursday you get
a little extra dose of Annie each week
at anniewood
um it's so fun I love it it's my little
baby so come babysit with me see you
then
now kalila what are some things that I
didn't know you worked at the Prada
store
you got a job that's okay
am serving up employee I know it's a
little bit of like stagehand or Usher it
looks like you work at a mini golf
course I look like an usher with big
isn't that how
um
um football footballer Ronaldo um met
his uh wife
I think no she was working at the Prada
store or something like that and they're
so you always do think they're flirting
with you they're always like hi Miss
Annie yeah she worked at this I haven't
been here oh it's a Gucci store yeah see
she was an employee There's Hope Esther
for uh
lesbian I
revealed last week I've said that those
things were not revealed I was with the
fans that you were gay baiting let's
recap all the time I was like she's
queer baiting she's faking wait what's
the recap repeat she said she was like
when I was little I was so worried I was
gay I became suicidal so you're a
lesbian so you are a lesbian I'm not
coming forward with a label my decision
her fiance has cute a cute lob let's
just say that
I don't have a decision I'm a creature
and then you were like is it weird that
I really was like attracted to this
lesbian and then she transitioned into a
man oh that you're attracted to a woman
not a man there's nothing worried about
that there's literally nothing weird
about that I would like to know what
kalila does in the middle of the night
when she wakes up when she gushes blood
well um you guys know this I one time
well a couple things
the first time I ever had anal was in
the middle of the night wake up
um were you involved did you consent um
there was Ambien involved it was ambient
consent but you squished the ass you
pushed the ass up yeah yeah yeah but it
was on and I in the middle of the night
like you're you feel a little witchy
you're like I want to do something
different and so at that time it was
anal other things I've done since
um I woke up a friend a platonic friend
and had sex with him wait I like that
you said witchy because it is that is
very like um Wicked like I feel like the
wiccan girls were always giving their
butt
don't you feel like the wicked girls
were always like come here I thought
that was Catholic girls because they
can't do vagina any kind of those
muscles
I think what yeah
oh yeah okay let's not go there but you
were saying sorry I interrupted
um yeah so like it's just a witchy hour
and you do things you wouldn't normally
do when the sun come up with your guy
friend that you're in bed with and he
didn't say no and then I cried
afterwards when I came to myself and I
was sort of in like this like lucid
dream I was really horny he just I
knocked on his room and I was like just
started making out with him and then we
had sex he just let it happen and then I
went back in the room and I started
crying and then the next day I cried to
him I said I don't know what that was
like that'll never happen oh poor guy
he's been waiting for years he had been
waiting his whole life to get that he
was a roommate it was really not good on
me we always didn't have a sleepover
wait you know what I was thinking I was
just talking to Bonnie McFarlane about
this today because I ran into two of my
exes last night and I was like
but the thing is it's like and all good
um but like the reason you shouldn't
[__] Comics is not because of what
happens during the relationship it's
just that you have to see someone you
used to [__] every day that is high risk
it's not about because I always thought
it was like you don't want like the
reputation of being like a girl who
dates comics and they're like you know
they always say they write your jokes
for you and stuff even though
I'm not gonna name any names but a lot
of their punchlines that is true I've
always dated people that were just not a
part of my work Circle they're so out of
it so like when it's over it's over I
probably will never run into any of them
again why am I like I love that I run
into my exes at work you're sick like I
love it's such a pleasant surprise to be
like oh there's so and so you could
easily be like a Jeffrey Dahmer
you could so easily be something that
like chops people up and just keeps
their body parts that yes if you were
big enough to like roll a barrel
I think you would be like a like a
chocolate body murder we'll give her a
couple more weeks with Body by Cassandra
and she might be able to roll a barrel
it's yoga by Chris I love yoga once once
a month and it won't be a few weeks it
will be a little bit longer than that
because we do go once a week but I it's
funny you say that Annie you're not
totally wrong because I have this thing
with Dave where often I'll say like my
end goal for our relationship is to have
him in a jar and just like have him in a
jar well he has arthritis I feel like he
could fit in Good Luck no yeah the day
is coming that is kind of sweet
um I'm doing my makeup if there are body
parts that you would want to keep as uh
for everything in a jar but you can have
the whole body like what parts would you
keep of a guy of a guy of an ex let's
say okay let's say we lived in a world I
don't like them I don't hate them let's
say we lived in a world where if you
broke up with someone you'd have to give
a certain body part away
of your own you have to if you are in a
committed relationship and you let's say
you go Facebook or Instagram official if
that relationship ends you are obligated
by law to give one body parts I need my
parts
um he choose no you you can choose or no
yeah the other partner chooses but it
cannot be the genitalia because
obviously they'd have to carry that on
into the next relationship I'm trying to
be nice to people and let them live I'm
taking toes fingers oh that's thoughtful
fingers any hair tongue for the artist I
love artists maybe we swap tongues
um you know what that's a good body part
too I don't want your little ass tongue
like what would you actually want
besides lips and tongue right does the
um like what are no offense like what
are Dave's eyes gonna do in my next
season of life
for me
well this is actually interesting you
brought up the eyes because I did pay
for Todd's Lasik so I do feel an owner
I'm like have you ever bought the
ability of like sight for someone like
do you know how powerful I feel wait
that's so cool I want to do that I
bought him Vision imagine if he were to
ever [__] over I put it on my American
Express imagine if you were to ever do
it I think you'd be like his eyes out no
you you almost have the right too you
could like give them back I'm like what
porn are you watching I now have control
over that yeah you gave him sight Annie
I gave him sight that honestly we're on
to something I like this
sorry I'm doing the the people have
asked for a makeup list hey this is a
get ready with me yeah oh my god get
ready with me episode all right guys do
you want me on time or not you got to
make some choices
I'm a busy 80d [__] okay
I almost feel like you're better when
you're in this makeup well so here's the
thing I can't do it if you
guys want me on time that means they
have to wait like I'm not like sometimes
these [__] are like you're never
gonna know okay I know what I am so I go
I give full permission for people to
start without me
okay so no one is taking any body parts
from their exes no I hate the question
to be honest okay let's know what are
you taking bloody push it [__]
it's very pushy she [__] raped her
[__] roommate
and Tony was a mistake she slap raped
him it really surprised me about that is
that he did not even resist a little bit
not why does that support you know that
scares [__] you got like a [__]
Playhouse mirror that makes you look fat
that was It was kind of hot though he
was like half asleep too and he just
like wiped it all I think about is all
the men I've had sleepovers with and
shared beds with in my life and this has
just never come close to happening no
roommate no no man is ever in the middle
of the night made a move on it's so
funny that you're like Randy's size like
you're like the size of my own dog in my
bed with me if you're there like I
wouldn't even be thinking do you sleep
at the foot of the bed
where do you sleep are you you sleep
I only know you as like a couch sleeper
I've never walked in and seen you
sleeping in your are you a side sleeper
uh are you like an inside
a stomach sleeper are you separate are
you touching during sleep are you no we
can't touch because Dave wears his mask
you can catch so [__] touch yeah no
did you give him sleep apnea you just
started shoving things up his nose at
night and I was like I can't breathe
um you guys don't touch at all not like
at sleep yeah Bobby had a weird thing
about that it's like even if my toe
would like graze up against him he would
like I would move away and it would
really hurt my feelings so now because
I'm so programmed to not touch a partner
during sleep oh that like like the last
person that I had like a sleepover with
a boy
um
I would I would be really careful not to
like touch any of his like his feet or
anything he's like what's what's going
on and if I Would by accident I would
pull away he's like what is that I was
like oh I think I thought you were gonna
yell at me for maybe I sleep I have a
controversial opinion about threesomes
that I would like to share and get here
I have
been thinking
and I look I'm a very open person I I
think everything in life is fluid I
think like
whatever but I actually believe that sex
should only be between two people at a
time I don't think threesomes make any
sense I've never had one everyone I know
seems to have had one I feel like it's
so complicated like someone's gonna feel
left out I I just I don't think they
should exist as a pillow princess you
should really lean into that you lay
back you go you do that you just have to
be the one that's doing nothing oh I
didn't think you have to be the one
that's being service I I will say this
the first time you get into a threesome
with someone it's the same way like like
it's as if you're hooking up with just
even one person for the very first time
you bang teeth things are awkward things
are not like choreographed well you
don't know how the other moves you don't
know the other kisses it's just like his
banging teeth like weird I've never not
banged me that I know okay banging teeth
I I've never had a successful threesome
until I did it every day you
domesticated it yeah like and and like
the first time it happened it was like
maybe in theory it was hot that that's
why I was turned on but it didn't become
like a well-oiled machine until we did
it over and over and over again
okay and and then it was fun and then
it's like oh this is starting to get
really creative and who was the well and
who was the oil
as both I can't
um not to shift gears in a really big
way but I've been doing some thinking
and I want to pose a question and get
your guys's opinion on that should you
get buccal fat removal no [__] I almost
got that in my 20s I'm glad oh my God
you did that I know you would actually
like your age would be sad I was so
insecure about my cheeks forever in my
20s like I just hate them so much I me
and Jenna would like look up the surgery
and talk about it and send pictures
back then because we have a friend that
got it done oh that's right yeah yeah
yeah a girl you don't know right yeah
yeah yeah you don't know her but it's a
it's a friend and and maybe she loves it
maybe she doesn't I just think that as
your face I always I was always told and
it was always reinforced that like my
big cheeks were a great thing and I I
never thought because I have obviously
my mom has like massive she's very
cheeky my little family's big on the
cheeks and I remember
I always knew one day that it would it's
like you just look at it and you're like
oh this this is fat this is fat on my
face like this looks youthful like why
would I ever try to that would take that
out that was ultimately why I didn't do
it because I was like I think I will
regret it later I'm just gonna stick
this out and I'm glad I did but I
totally you know a big part of it was
like one of my first few dates with Dave
he was like oh I saw this video you made
where you talked about things you don't
like about yourself and you just
mentioned your should you send it to
them does that what you do on dates look
at this first and he was like you
mentioned your cheeks and then he I'll
like never forget the moment where he
was like I think your cheeks are
beautiful and I was like like because
I've never felt that way about them and
so now I'm like okay anything works it's
such like if you think it's such a baby
thing to be like upset about like we
it's like insecurities of when we're so
little you know yeah like I remember
when I was really little looking down
and being like my thighs are fat and I I
was always friends with grown-ups
obviously as a kid weirdly and my like
30 year old friend was like you I think
your thighs are fat like you're nine
yeah it's like you're just like it's
like little things that you like no it's
like babies stuff that stays in your
head forever which the the main takeaway
should be that like no matter what
you're insecure about someone else will
like it so just [__] pretend that
it's oh I saw this thing on Tick Tock
that was like that this girl's therapist
said pretend that exactly who you are
and what you look like is the standard
of beauty what if you were the standard
of beauty I am that's so sad you have to
pretend it's not fair you are so pretty
blonde blue-eyed [__]
but it does help like hi Hitler oh wait
that transitions to my next talk and
what happened to you I don't know what
happened on now we're going to the
segment called trash Jews day
don't make me laugh so hard I will bleed
into this yellow
question for you that you're gonna be
surprised by
it's more of a debate to consider oh is
it about semi-glutids what's that also
you so crazy to just say that I'm
talking about yes we were talking about
the semi-glutids no like ozempic oh
something is guys everyone's gonna be
dead in a month we really want
everyone's gonna be dead in a month from
the bird flu or from ozempic
who is why are we and by the way
why are there just like fat men missing
legs that can't control his epic what's
going on well it's because it is like
you it's
it's a privileged thing to be able to
get ozone big there are a lot of people
that actually need it who aren't getting
it because you know
is it a weird day hoarding it I was I I
[__] have been seeing commercials for
ozempic so I don't feel anyone who's
taking it that isn't supposed to be well
then why is it being advertised to the
average American like that's I'm a mad
at the board diabetes
yeah oh yeah dude you know what I'm not
stupid no I'm not it's not if you're if
a doctor will give it to you it's not
your fault but it is like you're like I
think it could be dropping down I think
Lisa Marie was on opiates in her thing
in her autopsy it was like opiates and
ozone it was if you're losing 25 pounds
in two weeks that's bad for you no
that's not good and it's not good for
your face but do your thing I don't I
have friends that are on it I don't
judge it
I don't judge it but I definitely would
be personally scared and I think people
should like do that I think it has weird
like interactions with things and stuff
look I'm just gonna do some setups do
you know what I mean or not well what
you're the nurse what's your take I just
don't like how there is like it's
disproportionate
um in its distribution right now where
it's like people that actually need it
that's everything in our society right
right but also it's not just like a
supplement it's like a [__] it's a
shot that it's crazy but then I would
say the same argument about filler about
like anything that work people just do
and that there's no like historical
research and now people are having
trouble dissolving all those problems
are like this is like you're eating
injured yeah you're dealing with
something systemic when you're talking
about like cosmetic stuff that's I mean
of course there are um side effects like
serious side effects that can happen you
can get an occlusion when you um have a
filler you can cause blindness those are
the really really rare side effects
right like pure filler can move yeah it
can Botox remember yeah those are still
recently those are still relatively
um I I don't know it's like a small okay
smaller and rarer side effects and
something that happens when you have
like a systemic body changes that affect
all of your organs if you're losing 25
pounds in a month and I don't know
people will always stand by it because
it is obviously a very effective drug
I'm just curious to see how this is all
going to pan out like long term for
people who don't need it who are using
it but also isn't it like isn't it like
a weight surprise or a appetite
suppressant which that I've never been
hungry when I'm eating when I'm gaining
weight it's not because I'm satiating
hunger that's the same I always eat for
taste I don't eat for Hunger so it's
like I'm not like if I'm if I'm becoming
obese it's not because I'm like hung I'm
like oh it's lunch time let's eat yeah I
mean so I'd be the [__] that that eats
through it probably I think I just not
to like I'm shady and scary I definitely
I'm like oh I think my sister should go
on ozempic no there are a lot of people
that could probably benefit from
sleeping no don't bleep it
but that's what I'm saying is I do think
for people who struggle with their
weight I'm like why can't they but what
do you think is going to go wrong with
it
um I mean I just like Annie said like
there is you have girls who are already
of a normal BMI right by whatever
standard and these are girls who are
generally healthy but who are looking at
the waif skinny friend who are like oh
no I want to do that so now they're
taking a medication to fit a trend and I
just can't see like I I'm sorry like
that that seems like only an insane
negative outcome can come from that
you're right or and then if you get off
of it yeah you don't want to stop
shooting the root cause of why yeah
you're imagine all the people with
already with eating disorders now now
they have this magic thing that they can
take without having to purge without
having to deal with any of the
um hiding or any of that now they can
just Boop that's it I'm gonna be way
thin
and I don't know it's just I think I
think they'll probably find that like
losing weight that fast is pretty hard
on the heart and yeah your organs or
something it's got to yeah it's got to
no you guys are right
I'll go I'll leave but no can I get to
my real eyes a real serious question
and I want serious answers okay this
better be serious I'm gonna [__]
punch you if it's not serious okay and I
want you to really think about it
should the world know who Anne Frank is
oh it is trash Tuesday
because think about it
if you're about to say she lost are you
if you're a little girl do you want the
whole world to read your diary
my dad got me Kurt Cobain's diary for
Christmas one year and I was so
uncomfortable I was like I don't want to
read this it's like in someone's diary I
think that it's amazing and obviously
we've learned so much and like it's
really cool and it's been good for the
world but as a once as someone who was
once a small Jewish girl with a diary I
don't want people to read that or know
about it
the dairy of Anne Frank right here
um Esther what was on there
um that you I never read it
how about the real questions would you
want the world to re to know your diary
and after if you guys want to read my
let me just give you a little hint of
what my diary is okay it goes dear diary
today I woke up feeling and then I
completely forget I'm writing
then it's it's a few more lines it's
picked up in a different pen and it says
buy tampons and then it goes and then
it's a couple more lines in a different
pen and it goes um
dad's dick question mark I want to work
on a bit
it's all put together there's nothing
well the saddest thing is if you
actually did read my diary from
elementary school it would be like my
weight and what I ate which is really
that's so sad oh how hot that girl was
the Saturn are you I have an
announcement to make I have an
announcement to make after we can take
this out if this is too personal for you
but I know um Annie you think you know
we've we've made fun of me on this show
because I wanted to be a poet once upon
a time and I really really thought that
that's where my life was gonna take me
um I just found out that little Esther
here also had some poetic aspirations
Once Upon a Time okay I have to say that
I am a hypocrite and when I was I was
projecting when I made fun of kalila's
poems because my sister recently sent me
a poem that I wrote after my dog died
and it was
it was a poem and I wrote it and I want
to admit something though was it for
credit when I first read it I thought it
was about a boy until one line when you
said I'm gonna miss you running across
the lawn up until that point to the very
end I was like oh my God this is about
her ex-boyfriend no they're they don't
miss her running across their lawn
people can are we allowed to read it
sure oh
I can't wait to hear that these years
the way you guys made me read my book
though okay yeah but hers is what a dog
yours is just like emo emotions but this
is just you know what oh this is so
embarrassing but whatever who cares
okay yes I'm locked in I have a poem but
it's good
[Laughter]
it's also really long
oh it's I this is so I'm so cringy I
need it I need support give me a pep
talk Esther
you already suck
nothing can get worse from this okay
you're dressed like you work at a
[__] store waiting for Ronaldo
okay
also I was sent via email from my AOL
screen name Bella dancer G
um oh that's so PC compared to what I
thought your email I had some other ones
that were mine was Anne frankfan 69. was
it really I have that Yahoo email
address lucky girl mine was Pop That
[__] it was it was those are legal to
have yeah and then my second was tickle
me702 gmail.com and they said she asked
for it
all right here we go I'm just gonna make
it fast I really can't explain the
sadness that I feel it's hard to think a
day will come when all this pain might
heal few memories exist in my mind where
you do not appear making it hard to
believe you are no longer here
throughout my childhood you were the
only one always there you listened to my
secrets when no one else would care oh
my God this is the dog did not carry
killed himself jumped in front of a
[__] car he's like I want to hear
this bunch of Secrets and never can I
remember us having a single fight you
even reassured my safety every single
night because of your existence I never
felt alone looking back at our lives
together I can't believe how much we've
grown whenever you ran away I'd always
think I'd Die For Him throwing myself in
front of cars to assure you'd safely get
back in oh you have that in common with
them up until this point I still thought
it was about a boy I love that he ran
away by the way your daughter that was
like get me away from this girl she was
a runner were you like um
were you like like what's the Elmira
yeah were you like nice squeezy yeah I
was yeah he I don't think he likes come
here Mr gazelli that girl
um uh the weirdest part in all this is
that there is no going back who else
will get up in the middle of the night
to join me as I snack middle of the
night
everything makes sense
walking in the house without you there
to greet me will forever be so painful
that I almost guarantee I miss you tons
it hasn't been even one full day I don't
know how I'll live going on this way and
every time I think wow he's really gone
I wish I could take you for a walk or
watch you race across our lawn I'll
always look back fondly and probably
shed a tear because it seems impossible
that you will not be here
heartbreaking I know I really love Dusty
this is like also so adds up to
everything from the therapy episodes
like I had no one but Dusty
uh-oh my bully is looking at you ahead
everyone
lean into the fact that your parents are
alive and love you Esther they're gonna
be dead okay we have to forgive love I
do forgive and I do love but look at
this is like when I called my dad listen
when I called my dad master that was
beautiful thank you when I called my dad
and I was like I think I'm dyslexic he
was like Annie what are we doing at this
point it's like let them just you're
lucky look at the good the good no I'm
looking at the good but I actually it's
it is was this when your dad was at the
casino I'll give you that was this
casino time period we added the dusty um
pass of old age yeah he was he died when
I went away for freshman oh yeah I was
older than that than I than you might
think when I wrote that poem I was 19.
she was already doing comedy she was
dating Tony I would be in two years oh
my God I was two years from being a
comedian dating Tony
that's so dark
I was a child
don't flip that no you were too grown to
do the poem I'm not too young to date a
person wait so um
wait so how did Dusty pass he had
Cushing's Disease oh and were you around
I came back to say goodbye yeah and then
my dad took us all to Maggiano's and we
each got to get our own dessert for the
first time the night that
putting a pet down is quite possibly a
wound that never heals well do you watch
like do you go in and watch I watch my
last dog Sprout I went in and I watched
oh when he didn't Sprout did he I cannot
have this conversation is hell you have
to have it but I think there's something
that um ramdas says about death that
like really really Rings true for me and
it's like there is no like like death is
like as true as life gets like there is
no bigger truth than watching someone
transition like nothing is more pure
nothing is more I watched my father take
his last breath I watched um Sprout take
her last breath and it allows me to
recognize that
um all the love that I feel that and it
allows me to kind of know that the grief
that I'm feeling is really just love
with like no place to go and I lean into
it I'm like okay I don't want this wound
to heal this is a love that will never
go away so this is a wound I'm okay not
healing they have there's this poem this
line from upon this card that's like
similar to that where she's like every
time you run across my lawn it's this
wonderful poet
um very a little older than you'd think
uh she said roses are red violets are
blue I miss you where are you I miss
picking up your poo
um
yeah but it's like grief is just
um love and a heavy coat thank you yeah
I don't know sorry girl I don't know
what your name is but it's a coupon
thank you yeah but I think that um it's
different for everybody but I I find
relief knowing I'm there till The Bitter
End and sometimes I like that yeah and
and I imagine it would have been harder
for me to not have been there when my
father died do you know what I mean like
if it was like sudden and I didn't have
time to come home but it made it a lot
easier for me to know that okay like I
was here and like we're good I I see how
I see how he went who else was there
my mom and my sister and my best friend
and it was really weird because my best
friend was like she didn't had never
seen anyone in that state before even
really sick and we were teenagers and my
dad had like a gangrenous foot because
there was no more like blood perfusing
to his legs and so his toes were like
black basically and she had this weird
coping mechanism like we were cry
laughing like when we left his room it's
like very cathartic because she as as
his you could see his like things all
his machines start to kind of you know
go out
she was like just playing with his black
toe like what that was her way of coping
she was just kind of like hyper focused
on the toes
and yeah it was like really strange and
then I remember like that image of her
like it's just so like comical to me and
such like I don't know like I I think
about it fondly like it was sad but also
[__] funny because I was watching my
best friend like unable to deal with a
situation and just like choosing a toe
to kind of like pet I love it I I think
I'll actually love that you have that
funny silly thing that's a part of that
memory like I I think that is like how
we all cope I know we talk about this a
lot but it's like I the the big laugh
that Dave and I shared at my
grandfather's funeral is like one of the
best memories of our relationship it's
like my aunt gave this speech that was
nonsensical and like so long and [__]
stupid yeah that's right I'm saying it
on camera I don't yeah and after but
after she gets down from the Pew or
whatever she just gave this speech about
her father who passed away my she walks
past my grandma and in the nastiest tone
my grandma just looks at her and goes
way too much and like me and Dave just
lost our [__] it was so funny and like
obviously my aunt said too much but it's
like Grandma like her dad died like
[__] letter
you don't have to be a [__] at the end
I don't know it was it was hilarious
I think you need those moments of levity
my dad's funeral there was a woman um
sister Cleo who sang Amazing Grace and
she saw saying it's so awesome
[Laughter]
um but she sang off key the whole time
and you know like when you're in a
classroom with someone and you're trying
to like not laugh and it only gets worse
and it'd be the laugh becomes bigger you
have to excuse yourself out the
classroom that's basically my sister and
I like they really are the best [__]
moments no you know there's so hard not
to she's like shove your like sleeve in
your mouth like trying to yeah
when that happened to me in college it
was funny like you're very grown to be
having this happen I'm like I cannot
stop laughing
foreign
look we had merch once we had merch for
three days and we will have merch again
and we love merch again and we're using
ship station in a landscape where free
and fast shipping is the norm it can be
hard for smaller e-commerce businesses
to compete keep yourself competitive
with ship station shipstation makes it
easy to grow your business by handling
your orders from every Marketplace in
One dashboard shipstation effortlessly
integrates everywhere you sell online
including Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify and more I'll say I
feel like everyone nowadays like has a
small business and as some as all of us
who have like gone through that using
shipstation just makes it so much more
simple it's like cleaner and there's so
many little things you have to take into
consideration when you're like shipping
and doing this kind of stuff that ship
station just is it makes it very easy I
can't even ship myself here on time do
you think I can ship my articles of my
pieces of business to you guys and you
can manage every order from one simple
dashboard automate routine shipping
tasks print shipping labels easily
compare rates and delivery times to
optimize every shipment and automate
delivery notifications my favorite part
is that with the best discounts in the
industry you will never worry about
overpaying for shipping get up to 84 off
USPS and UPS rates and if that's not
enough use our promo code to try
shipstation for free two months keep
growing your business all year long with
shipstation use promo code trash Tuesday
today at shipstation.com to sign up for
your free 60-day trial that's
shipstation.com promo code trash Tuesday
Annie how do you take your ag1
oh I got one of those little Shaker
things I put it in my water I shake it
up and I chuggity chug chug chug baby
and it's so mild tasting yeah you can
add it to your smoothie it doesn't
overpower
um the taste of your smoothie I like to
add a little bit of apple cider vinegar
and I use my little matches sure and put
a little bit of ice and it is so good
you guys you know I was a chugger in
college I can't chug much I like to I
used to chug Jaeger now I chug athletic
greens and it's a really like fun way to
start my day I feel more energized I
feel I'm doing something really nice for
myself I have to say I do feel like
amongst all the successful people I know
athletic greens is like the thing that
they all have in common like successful
people taking not like ignoring you when
you try to talk to them well that's also
there second on the list like as a
person that can be you know lean more
towards disorganized lifestyle ag1 makes
it so simple like all the nutrients
nutrients that I'm looking for are in
one place one powder all in one Fell
Swoop not having to like mismatch like
yeah I don't have time to be like how
many milligrams of this thing how many
of this how many pills of this it's like
enough and you guys it's just one scoop
of powder mixed with water once a day
and every scoop is packed with 75
vitamins minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients of the highest quality that
give us major benefits like gut and mood
support boosted energy and even
healthier looking hair skin and nail and
if you're looking for an easier way to
take supplements athletic greens is
giving you a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to go to
athleticgreens.com Tuesday that's
athleticgreens.com Tuesday check it out
yeah this isn't a funeral obviously but
my this podcast well it could be if you
keep up your behavior if you keep
wearing low-rise pants you [__] [__]
I'm out by the way
mark my words if she wears these again
we're done this is not fair you're you
need to be mad at Trend Cycles not me
I'm a victim of the trends you're basic
that I know I want to be basic that's
not a bad thing Dr Drew said simple and
safe you weren't there's nothing safe
about you
your parents aren't safe you're finding
new things they abused you with no one's
safe around Esther
she's gonna justifiers that sounds like
the tagline to a horror movie and it is
a real Esther in that movie that you
look like the girl by the way the orphan
I know um okay so my my brother okay so
when my brother got married
my twin brother my mom was in charge of
the rehearsal dinner
my mom had just had a high school
reunion with her girlfriends from her
boarding school where her one of her
friends was like a folk singer with her
husband and they did like silly songs
now if you're meeting up with your
girlfriends from high school and they're
singing it's funny right it's like okay
silly funny like sex innuendos and these
songs whatever my mom hires her to be
the musical Talent of my and my brothers
used to my mom's [__] okay
my sister-in-law Dana is a is she's a
real
regular beautiful person that's used to
regular normal life okay
I love those people it's like wrong
family [__]
um we love you Dana you make us a little
normal but so she so my mom hires this
woman and it's like her it's in a
restaurant for small word they're like
can we turn the music down in the whole
restaurant the restaurant's like no so
they're like through like there's like
you know like Third Eye Blind it's
playing in the background and they're
like have a little keyboard and they're
singing like weird like the fish go
Upstream they have like
stuff like it's just so cringe so
ridiculous so embarrassing like
everything's a sex joke it's like these
old people singing this to just like my
sister-in-law's family and my family and
I think about it and it's like if my mom
had gotten like a band that ruled we
wouldn't even think about it right it's
like we wouldn't even remember this
thing now it's [__] amazing yeah but
it's like I guess like so like you do
want someone to talk [__] at a funeral
you do want someone yeah you know what I
mean like you want things to go wrong
someone to wiggle your dad's dying toe
or whatever I'll tell you like we we'd
never remember Perfect Weddings perfect
birthdays we always remember the ones
where [__] went down I need [__] to go
down not maybe like traumatic [__] but
some [__] to go yeah another like
favorite most imprinted Christmas memory
was the year I got an iPod video and I
immediately uploaded the Pam and Tommy
porn on it sorry I know that's wrong of
me but that was what I did first and
then I have all sides guys and then I
was looking at it and from across the
room my mom shouts whose dick is that
and like that was a quote so she was
present
paying attention on Christmas
um so yeah whose dick is that was a
quote for a long time with me and my
sister I never saw that tape really well
I didn't have a computer or Internet
yeah come on over
my dad was always watching all the Celeb
porns my dad really come first yeah well
my brothers would like go like buy porn
from people like down the street and so
when they caught my brothers buying porn
my mom just had my dad get Playboy and
then all of the kids could just take it
oh yeah yeah yeah so that they wouldn't
like spend their money
thank you
sorry was so surprised by you last time
I didn't see you in the corner
um I this is why I cannot be dating by
the way can I give you example of why I
could possibly like really chase a boy
away if I were to yes please so
um I was I was with a boy
and
um my period was right around the corner
as I was feeling extra emotional you
know how it is where you're just all of
a sudden unearthing all of your
childhood core wounds and I said two
things that I I fully regret now that my
estrogen is back on the rise
I said two things and with full tears in
my eyes because I asked them I was like
do you like crows and ravens and he was
like yeah like I like them they're like
cool birds and then with full tears in
my eyes I was like because I think there
is a crow inside me
crying and I had to explain to him like
my connection to corvids why I think I
do Ayahuasca there's nothing weird about
anything I know literally yes there is a
pro inside you [__] I'm so turned on by
that I'm like tell me more like I love
this and then the next day even now
closer to my period
I tell them a story about how I used to
crack rocks as a child looking for
certain crystals and I spent six months
um before my sister's birthday like um
collecting what I thought was the most
precious rocks that had ever cracked and
I put them in a really fancy box and on
her birthday
um she opened that gift last and all of
my mom and my aunts and everyone they
were like what is that and Karina was
like oh kalila cracked rocks for me and
she gave me her most like Precious
crystals and they all laughed
they were like rocks and they all like
cackled and I remember feeling so
humiliated and and
um and feeling like I just spent six
months like where are they not
collecting these rocks and my sister
chased me upstairs she's like I love
them I love them I swear and I was
really embarrassed because I was only
nine and I told this story to the boy
again with full tears in my eyes and I
was like I used to crack rocks really
crazy like precious rocks and I I
honestly think he closer than smoking
[__]
am I allowed to be this vulnerable this
early on in a thing because I think I'm
just gonna people are gonna think I'm
insane do you remember that headline
from a few months ago was like the
clingy girls were the right ones it's
like if you we know someone who didn't
forget that one did you did you hang it
up like it was about you you framed it
be yourself like yeah that's so
interesting what you just said and also
that's such a core wound that you carry
and it's so good to like let it out and
I'm glad you shared it with us because
like I have things like that too where I
remember when I this is why I don't know
how to ride a bike because one of the
times where I was being taught like a
what what
a car full of fly you don't even know
what I want to say was it a car full of
me laughing at you just several me I'm
in every seat laughing at you it was a
car full of cool guys and they looked at
me and they laughed and then I was like
I can't I'm not doing this I've never
I'm a cool guy laughing
oh God that is so funny so Kyla I just
think you have so much in common and
like we should really like kiss
Thank You Esther be yourself always be
always be the crow that you have in you
thank you yes I want to say one more
thing about crows
[Laughter]
it's this old I can't ride a bike
you're nothing uh
thank you
a hidden brain but it was one of the NPR
ones about a girl who just like in her
30s 30s decided to join a community of
people who don't know how to ride bikes
and they all get together and they learn
I think you should do that so there's no
humiliation of doing it alone
no I think you should do it on here and
we should humiliate
is what she likes
a little bit I think I'm not humiliated
anymore it's I'm scared okay one more
idea I don't want to get hurt one more
idea how about we all get hurt we pick a
day of the week we wake up at three in
the morning and we teach Esther how to
ride a bike I mean why we're gonna give
it three is in the middle of the night
but also
if you make one more plant with the
[__] that you don't follow through on
I'll [__] scalp you I will be wearing
your hair I said yes I wasn't the one
who said no to steak dinner I said yes
whenever what are your sides
a twice baked potato would be my first
choice gummy bears jelly beans
what's what sides would you be going for
definitely before spinach caused um
extreme you know GI pain for me it used
to be like cream spinach oh that's not
um or I love from Boston Market yes oh
my God that feels like a boyfriend from
middle school like I'm like oh so you
know my one of my biggest my boyfriend
from middle school worked at Boston
Market I think maybe that's I love
Boston I'm nostalgic for me it's one of
the first American things I really enjoy
why is the [__]
um the ice skating rink all your ice
skating rink that I used to like make
out with boys that close down that's
painful where are the kids fingering
each other now they found another cut
for sure yeah where where do they finger
each other nowadays I don't think they
think do they finger
do they wait until they're old enough to
write a poem
well it's like they the little toddlers
watch porn nowadays so it's like they
probably just go straight to face
[__] do you know that when you read
that poem I was like proud of you
thinking you were like finding all these
rhyming words at five I was like oh my
God
long gone we'll do it it's close enough
I think we all have Late Bloomer
qualities Maybe
could put the sex stuff like early but
almost like forced early yeah not like
um yeah not in a good way really
um but with other things oh my God such
a late bloomer there are a lot of things
I'm just learning even at this age that
I'm just like what the [__] I didn't can
I tell you what I did for the very first
time I'd like to admit something and
this might sound really silly I went
through a drive through for the very
first time three weeks ago my first time
alone which one and it was I was all the
way in Corona because I was like
visiting this like Factory out there and
I was falling asleep and I was like I
just need something to drink so I went
through a Starbucks drive-through and
when I got to the thing I was like I
don't know how to do this I've never
works count I've never done this before
how have you never I remember how do I
know how do I host a podcast with you
you've never had done a drive through
myself I've been through a drive-through
with other people as like the driver or
a passenger but I never have done it are
you getting triggered are you
remembering a certain Taco Bell order
what wait what do you remember when you
ordered so many things on Taco Bell that
you got that everyone
now I can handle those things come for
me I don't care I have annoying ass
orders
but special but again I'm 38 and that
was the first time I ever did something
and I remember I drove home with so much
like wind in my sails what'd you get
what order did you get yeah I got the
sous vide egg bites and then I got a
breakfast sandwich and a decaf coffee
and I drove home like listening to
Maggie Rogers and thinking am I an adult
and I felt different all because of a
drive-through I actually relate to that
when I was in high school the first time
I did a drive-through myself like you do
feel like a grown-up I mean I had it at
a better like more appropriate time and
I did get a chocolate cake shake from
Portillo but you drove yourself there
yeah and it's like so empowering right
guys I I don't know how to relate to
this I was like we were getting Taco
Bell every day what is but by yourself
is a big deal by yourself I do like a
nice road trip by yourself you know what
I do at Taco Bell bathrooms you know I
have a good time wake up I get ready to
write some papers and drive you know
well that's the thing it's like I've
traveled alone so much in my life like
I've done so many things so long ago I'm
like how the [__] have I not done this
basic ass thing technically you're not
alone they're there helping you yeah
it's a connection thanks Annie I um yeah
I do like a drive-through it does piss
me off when you are walking by
a drive-through and they don't allow you
to walk through it I always thought the
same piss me off that's a little silly
isn't it it's just like come on yeah I
have money takes a bike and I've been
served you have yeah on a bicycle
wait that's alone you know how to write
it on the peg yeah on a date no it
wasn't a date did you fall off that's a
very like no cholo culture thing it's
really cute thank you I've definitely
been on a lot of pegs yeah on bikes yeah
I've never been pegged I've just [__]
in the ass like a classic way
have you ever pegged no have you I
haven't I had to wear a strap-on for
Girl Code once that was exciting yeah
I'm open to it but all the producers
like I I posted like a clip of me
talking about it on stage because I was
like put the strap on and I was like
slapping everything off tables I was
like slapping them in the face like I
was slapping like I went I was like oh
my God guys like I get it I see why you
guys have to put your penises places
like it's crazy it's like a you have a
sword and um and so the pretty I posted
it and then all of the producers who are
like stuff on me like we were there we
were slapped this happened this is real
validated
which one's mine you're sexual when you
assaulted everyone with your fake penis
they put it on me it's their fault
but I think that's a really silly thing
when people like don't allow you to just
go through a drive-through I don't know
if it's like a it's like a oh maybe it's
they think it's dangerous because the
car is going to like come by oh you know
knock you from the boat I don't know
that has to be it yeah yeah
it's like you're losing money I wanna
but also the people who work there don't
care about the money but don't you think
it's a little bit classist yeah because
it's like I don't [__] have a car to
drive through here I'm Barefoot and
hungry and sometimes the drive-through
is anything that's open and not the end
no I know it's like I hate when it's
only the drive-through yeah let me eat
I'm hungry I if it's the choice between
going inside in the drive-through how
are you ever not just choosing drive
through I will go in I need sometimes
you just need to be like can you get
this for me waiting in her car it's like
you'd have less control
love the car is the safe space there's
some ultimate control there's people to
meet inside people to chat with
I have a question okay oh shoot I think
it's mostly for kalila because it
doesn't really apply to us but like
would you rather be a nude model in an
art class or do stand-up comedy
um
today yeah well not with like your
period shouldn't affect the decision but
um
probably a nude model really yeah
stand-up comedy is is
it's absolutely terrifying it's not it's
not for me
you don't think I've tried going to open
Mike's and Bobby was like you should
just try it just to see how I feel and
so I would go a couple times and I'm
like I [__] I don't have I don't feel
that thrill I don't feel that Pride I
don't feel like that W and you like no
it was it was absolutely awful for me I
that makes sense like I feel like most
people would say that I was thinking
about it because when I was in my first
year of college I did like a nude naked
modeling for an art class once and I
like that was everyone arrested for
their drawings this is Kitty porn
I what did they all use like those
little like golf pencils
[Laughter]
well it's actually goes back to
something you were saying at the
beginning of the episode right before
that how are you posed how many poses I
think it was two poses and they were I
was
bread bowl I think I just kind of like
stood there like I actually I think I
was like
like this or something because I
remember like my one leg was forward and
did you spread or did you I could not
spread I did not spread
um were you feeling like self-conscious
and like regretting so I was really
nervous about doing it she can't ride a
bike she's naked in front of a whole
class okay but I had read in Madonna's
biography that she had done this when
she was like a struggling singer dancer
and I was like I have to do everything
Madonna did and so I signed up and I was
nervous but I was like I can do whatever
I'm just gonna do it and while I was
there I think I was fine
obviously standing for a long time is a
lot harder than I thought it would be
but then at the end they're like oh you
can like walk around the class and see
what everyone Drew and the the most
distinct memory I have is [__]
looking at my thighs and being like
oh my God they don't really look like
that dude like I was like mad at the
students because I was like I can't
believe they because my thighs looked
like real thighs and not sticks were
they High School
no it was hot it was the college kids
but yeah I don't but now I would never
do that again I would be so scary I um I
used to go to the like drink and draw
this thing in Brooklyn where it was like
my friend Tim Ken amazing artist was my
teacher there he's so [__] good
um I will buy something from you one day
I promise but he um so it's like you
would go to this place in Brooklyn and
you would pay ten dollars and there was
like unlimited Pabst Blue Ribbon and
like chips and stuff and I don't know if
you brought your I think they had the
the drawing supplies and stuff and they
would just have like a nude model and it
was so fun but I never was the ma I
would rather be [__] shot in the head
yeah and have the bullet turn around and
should go back through the hole same
hole yes that you can draw that hole
you're not drawing I just don't like for
me it's like I'm like I am naked a lot
and my windows are open and people are
seeing me naked often but the idea that
everyone is staring at me naked and the
details and they're and they need to
look at yeah there's no like
um this is my side you know I find that
really interesting that um I kind of
feel similarly when my windows are open
and like I've been with people in the
house they're like oh I know you're
naked they can see it I don't care
either there was they used to say that
I'm like look if he's looking out his
window that's him looking out his window
trying to let you know what I mean it's
like it's not
right I I don't feel as like conscious
about it because it's just like it's
like just living life I have no
relationship I'm not related to him I'm
not gonna molest it like oh there's no
things were the best they want to see
there's probably the best case scenario
for him to just see the the you know
what I'm saying about you know I'm
friends how they have like they had like
the fat naked guy no I didn't watch
friends
we're a Seinfeld house you never want
both friends I don't think you can be
both
I think it's friends are Seinfeld it's
Christian and Jewish that is true you're
both but
but um I think you should watch friends
I think you would like it it's really
good
it's really funny I don't know it was
crazy I remember being in fifth grade
like this show is so good my teacher was
like your parents let you guys watch
Friends
oh that's weird it was really good but
but
um they had like this this fat hairy
naked neighbor that they would always
see was there an Esther I just feel like
that's it no but I'm just saying name
has no I'm just saying like no it was a
man it was like an uh balding man but um
who's maybe could be an Esther
but I realized like I am I'm that now
naked naked neighbor
so far I still feel like they're lucky
to see it but I was a cheers home
oh and a Frasier home that was my girl
you were a Frasier home that is such a
grandpa that's because her dad was old
yeah pretty sure that is the first
signing from old sperm if you're afraid
and and Norm from chew yeah cheers wow
also friends though but also Seinfeld so
a little bit of everything that's why
this show works I'm telling you to the
to the death I'm on my so-called life
[__] if that show had gotten a [__]
did you ever watch it yet no my sister
watched it we're waiting for the TV
while that was on Todd will like bring
up Jared Catalano or Jordan Catalano
like it's like a thing you can just
bring up without like sending me to A
Whole New World Jared Leto I am not
attracted to Jordan Catalano is like I'm
[__] kegling right now guys like I am
so like in love with this illiterate
greasy-haired
[__] high school [__] it's like
crazy I just but oh that's imprinting
like how crazy he imprinted on you that
me that looks I see me you're so off
[__] there's nothing me and a flannel
and a choker
bro that's [__] me
Esther I'm so sad for you
it's like you are pretty like I think
you're you don't know that you're pretty
but that is a different level
I did watch Romeo and Juliet again
was it still the bachelorman one it once
something imprints on you it's never not
good no I used to go to the library and
was I stealing I think I was stealing
yeah I think I would go to the library
and I would steal yes I would oh it's as
bad to steal from a library guys but I
would go to the library the magazines
pictures not for reading for pictures
yeah yeah yeah reading read the magazine
there was one article about huffing that
I remember cutting out what magazine and
me and my friend it was like 17 ym my
um
yeah my friend and I had like a joint
book that would send each other and it
was like we made this pack we would
never Huff
because it was like someone died from
huffing and People magazine that was a
really sweet childhood promise no
huffing listening I just tell you I did
not follow through oh my God
you huffed I'm a hufferer what is
huffing it's like yeah I don't like
paint and huff but if there's a whipped
cream bottle right yeah it ain't coming
out with air
laughs
it's huffing also with the um no with
like paint job like duster and stuff I
don't do that okay I don't like things
that make your brain squeak
it squeaks when you squeaky sounding
like smoking wet like weed that's dipped
I know can you look up what wet is
because it's not like actually from
Outer high but that's what they said it
was it's like PCP right yeah but what is
it dipped in actually getting one let me
see it's not actually formaldehyde
that's sherm
Sherm Pete knows but but we called it
what we called it what
oh that's just putting like weed
embalming fluid tobacco yeah and
embalming fluid Jesus yeah that's what
we used to smoke oh really so it's
basically a spliff dip
that we actually had cigarettes tobacco
in it oh there was no tobacco in it and
ours no you can but I'm sure most people
just use weed yeah we were just
wondering if a little squeaky it seem
like embalming fluid would be like a
good like alternative to Botox like if
it like keeps you as you are you dab it
on oh you already have some in your
mouth body parts
Esther's like I got some hand dude you
think it'll help we find an extra secret
why she looks so young
those baths are not with water I'll tell
you that those those monthly baths
weekly that would be you're coming in
quite greasy after your big thing about
how you are clean now ugh I that's
someone you put pressure on yourself I
literally washed my hair yesterday why
is it greasy already because you're
doing a lot of this and in your hands
are real greasy how often do you wash
your hair
um so I'm doing this new thing where
I don't really do things like how often
you know I just kind of like as I
remember as I feel it you're starting
this now she's doing intuitive washing
I'm trying to play it off like you had a
plan before
well my whole life I always was like am
I am I a person who bathes at night or
in the morning am I a person who is
everything I totally know what you're
saying yeah yes it's so annoying do you
remember I think with like eating stuff
too it's like how [__] hard breakfast
always was yes breakfast was always like
this thing I had to just like release
breakfast
for breakfast like Jesus Christ I think
that's like um one of the signs of any
disordered anything is like ritualistic
like what am I how do I identify as
either this or that you know like
there's always like a ritual involved
it's like if you feel some type of way
just jump in the shower who cares when
you wake up in the middle of the night
if you have the cash don't like spend or
save I'm gonna try that tonight it feels
so good because you're told to not
impulsively do things
in life you know like people are like
that's like bad but I'm like I'm leaning
into every [__] impulse and I'm just
gonna see what happens
please
I I don't want to like burst your guys
bubble about what you think of me but my
my impulses are not violent or negative
it's just funny to make fun of you
threaten your structure your small
structure I hope you have an Impulse I
like to make you feel unsafe on Earth I
do wonder that Annie because like like
my whole life I've fought impulses
because I can be super impulsive and
I've just I've prided myself in being
like I'm less impulsive now I'm grown
but I'm like have I robbed myself
there's a bunch of [__] I want to do if
I wake up in the middle of the night and
I'm like spinning and I go you know what
I really want to do I want to buy a
jacket look at me now [__] that's a
[__] epic outfit this was this would
not be a purchase during the day okay
this is a midnight purchase and Todd's
always like totally like oh God she's
shopping oh that's cute but it's great
and then they come and I'm excited
excited and it's [__] great there's
no like I'm a grown-up there's no one
telling me not to do this anymore
so I'm just gonna see how it goes and
then I but then it's like if it becomes
too much of a habit and I'm like oh I'm
not liking the things I'm getting then I
won't do it but how often are you waking
up in the middle of the night like what
time do you wake up to I usually have a
second wind I usually go to Second Wind
it is so funny I'm so energetic I know
where are you I I'm telling you like
there's been periods of times in our
lives where I feel like I talk to you
late at night and then at 7am you call
me the next day and you're like I
already had a day
good girl
um yeah no I um I don't know I'm excited
I like my life you're not to make this
like the Seinfeld episode but that's
like when Kramer was experimenting with
sleep schedules and he would like sleep
in like four hour chunks and then have
like four hours a week in the middle of
the night for it I think uh Kramer
needed a little more sleep when he did
that Laugh Factory
I've been a little
a little tired then middle of the night
another middle of the night
um Fiasco is yeah don't fire all your
impulses thanks for bringing up Kramer
don't follow along Roseanne Barr was the
middle of the night
um
I don't take sleeping pills
yeah I don't either I'm not a sleeping
pill [__] I just did it for anal that's
it
that's interesting well it's like they
said that anal being well they say like
if you if you force yourself to stay up
um when you take um you start it has
like a kind of a hallucinogenic effect
and it did
and which led to a relaxed butthole a
relaxed butthole and a very positive
experience because the the time that I
did anal before that I like a fever that
night and it was like horrible like I
went into shock I think well I just
never feel like the sleeping pills like
you're I don't feel like you're really
it's like you're faking yourself into
thinking you were sleeping like you're
not getting like actual rest it's like
so why am I doing this I'd rather know
I'm gonna be tired the next day than not
I had a boyfriend who actually helped me
with this because he was like kind of
like he was a real night guy too and I
used to get so mad at myself when I
couldn't sleep and that I remember the
day in third grade when my teacher I
might have said this on here before
because it is like definitely a core
memory my third grade teacher was like
we have a really important test tomorrow
make sure you get sleep ice that was the
moment my sleeping problem started
because it was a pressure of having to
do something yeah so then when I
wouldn't be sleeping like [__] I'm not
sleeping I'm not sleeping and it would
be like my day tomorrow's gonna be
ruined it'd be like this future like
Dread and now
I had a boyfriend who was like
he's like you're talented you're good
you're able to like work with no sleep
he's like whatever sleep you get tonight
will not you can still pull it off so
him doing that was good for me because
it released this sort of like pressure
of like things having to be like I have
to sleep in hours if I don't you know
it's gonna ruin everything because then
I'm like setting myself up so now I
really don't even look if I'm having
trouble sleeping or if there's something
like I do want to get sleep I never look
at the time because I don't want to like
be starting a really good trick yes so
it's like I don't even know how it's
like it's like as much as you can it's
the same psychology behind saying like
you know like no no Foods don't eat that
don't eat that because then that's all
you're thinking about if you're saying
like get enough sleep get enough sleep
all you're thinking about is not yeah
not sleeping basically no you're
worrying about nothing you're so right
like the the No-No foods like I can
never have if someone's doing a diet
we're like I can never have bread
anytime I've ever tried that by three
o'clock that day I've had the most part
I've ever done oh
like I truly are like oh I'm giving up
sugar three o'clock that day I have
three pints of ice cream in my freezer
that I just picked up and I'm going it's
like if you wake up in the morning
you're like I'm totally gonna eat
bananas today no so you cannot eat it
yeah you can't live in like absolutes
like that I think it's not healthy well
you're gonna swing back too yeah
remember when I did my uh my master
cleanse you're like good luck [__]
there will be a swing back yeah never
been skinny since
yeah it's that was the beginning of big
Annie
big girl time what was the master
cleanse it was Cayenne in it it just
blast your [__] it's just like hey do
you want to fire your [__] up for
[__] three weeks or whatever it's
like 10 days what wasn't it like lemon
water cayenne and maple syrup oh maple
syrup so you had a little bit of a blood
sugar boost but that's it but I will
tell you it is here's the crazy thing
you do realize like you could survive in
the wilderness for a long time like you
do realize like oh
I like my body is like
on a yeah and I see a benefit on
occasionally like forcing like you know
when David Sinclair talks about
um doing these like occasional fasts
yeah to kind of force sell death for the
cells that are kind of like no longer
useful but they need to be like killed
off
certain things like that make sense to
me but to do like a week-long master
cleanse to put your body into starvation
mode
it can't be for like you can't be doing
those things for any sort of like weight
loss or like it has to be like their
spiritual cleanses people do there's
like fasting you do just sort of like as
a sacrifice to like whatever program
you're doing or whatever but those
things are still for me like having been
disordered a lot in my life is still an
absolute I can't work with like if you
put me in like the confines of like you
this is the only thing you can drink a
day it's like already I'm spinning out
yeah also I remember in high school
reading in In Like Us Weekly or whatever
Beyonce use the master cleanse to look
to lose weight for the her role in Dream
Girls so it just I'm just like angered
by that that was like advertised to us
is like this is how you lose weight and
this is what the celebrities are doing
oh my god do you remember how badly you
wanted to know what the celebrities like
yes but you were like I want to know
every morsel that goes into your mouth
and the thing that's so funny about that
is like you get older I feel like once
you hit like 30 like mid 30s early 30s
it's like you realize like everybody's
so [__] different that there's not
any way what one other person does would
ever be the thing for you anyway if I
were to have done like uh this is what I
eat in a day they would know that I ate
a really dry piece of bread with turkey
slices you know over my sink this
morning because I was in a rush yeah
like that's not really like oh this is
what I and I boiled this I [__] off like
thank you I'm sure on a good day I can
do all of that but like that's just not
how life works you know it's like it's
so unrealistic I don't watch any of that
[__] I don't even like I don't allow my
brain to absorb that I don't allow my
brain to look at the positive results of
semi-glutides or the new whatever you
really wanted to talk about this I just
don't because it's like I what are they
what that's what brought it up Olympics
oh yeah yeah okay yeah I just well you
already knew that didn't you because
only because she brought it up earlier
not before that's what they're called I
didn't know that what
it's you've been looking into it I've
deaf oh you're the most Kardashian of us
here yeah no of course I know about
ozempic and I know like I've I started I
dare you the amount of questions
you would look like can you pull up the
David Cross the um the Mr show the guy
who gets burned in the in the
um it's like their Metallica parody can
you just look at Metallica I 100 would
not go on it but could I just show you
exactly what you would look like if you
did it but I don't want people to say
I'm just I want to know everything about
it oh my God this is so they're a band
and this is like their favorite band I
fell into he fell into a a thing of acid
when he was listening to their song Jump
Into acid jump into acid hey buddy try
it out and so they're like oh yeah
oh my God that's so simple
I dare you [__]
a little
[Applause]
bit
I see myself I feel like I feel so bad
Lord
but if you're only watch that [__]
sketch It's the funniest thing I've ever
seen you guys thank you so much for
watching this week's episode of trash
Tuesday
um if you don't need to be on ozempic
don't get on an Olympic also don't get
your bugle fat removed Annie and I can't
really fairly answer this question I
really am genuinely curious please
comment would you rather post nude for
an art class or do stand-up comedy can I
tell you I posed nude for an art teacher
and it made me a stand-up comedian
you just picked my entire like life my
entire like storyline of how I got here
so let us know what you'd rather do and
we'll see you next week with a brand new
episode
[Music]